déjà présent à paris lyon bordeaux ou
encore grenoble c'est au tour de sky de
bénéficier des trottinettes électriques
de tir mobility l'opérateur a été
sélectionné pour mettre en place ce
service suite à un appel à projets lancé
par l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en octobre dernier il a couché
tous les critères en obtenant une note
de plus de 18 sur 20 je pense notamment
la sécurité c'est un opérateur qui va
développer des engins avec un casque qui
va avoir des véhicules à 20
km/heure ce qui était important pour
nous c'est un opérateur aussi qui sur la
partie responsabilité environnementale
développement durable s'est montré très
performant sur le service qu'il
souhaitait déployer et puis surtout dans
la gestion du service dans la relation
client 250 stations devrait être déployé
sur l'ensemble des douze communes du
territoire pour 1000 véhicules
l'opérateur va implanter une équipe sur
saint quentin en yvelines
elle sera en charge de la maintenance du
service et des véhicules
ça comprend évidemment là la mise en
place des véhicules sur le territoire le
rééquilibrage également parce que on
veut servir l'ensemble des habitants
dont il faut bien répartir régulièrement
la flotte sur les différentes stations
et puis également une équipe qui
s'occupe de ce changement de batteries
la vitesse des trottinettes est limitée
à 20 km/heure
elles seront disponibles en libre
service à partir de 18 ans est
accessible via l'application tire c'est
aussi là que chacun va pouvoir choisir
son mode de fonctionnement donc je vois
à l' usage pour des pour des personnes
qui utilisent peu le service coûts de
manière non régulière soit pouvoir
bénéficier des abonnements et les
souscrire directement sur l'application
la mise en route de ce service
expérimental est prévue pour le mois de
juin
au total l investissement s'élève à 1
million d'euros sur un an pour
l'opérateur et 100000 euros de mises en
place pour l'agglomération